tonight is not only about celebrating
the people in front of the camera it's
also about recognizing the artists who
design the beautiful worlds our
characters inhabit let's take a look at
the incredible work they do creating the
overall appearance of their films here
are tonight's nominees for achievement
in production design black panther
production design by hannah Biegler and
set decoration by Jay Hart the favorite
production design by Fiona cromby and
set decoration by Alice Felton first
ma'am production design by nathan
crowley and set decoration by Cathy
Lucas Mary Poppins Returns production
design by John Mayer and set decoration
by Gordon sim Roma production design by
a haenyeo Caballero and set decoration
by Barbara Enrique's and the Oscar goes
to
this is the first Oscar and nomination
for Hannah be cooler
she is the first african-american to be
nominated in this category this is the
first win and third nomination for Jo
he was previously nominated in this
category for Pleasantville and LA
Confidential
[Laughter]
[Applause]
thank you okay you're on my dress
fake New Orleans you're me oh okay I
gotta put these on um and I don't even
know where I put my speech cuz I put it
in the phone and now I can't find it I'm
really shaking hard okay I want to thank
all of the nominees in this category for
extraordinary words worlds that they
built this year so honored to be a part
of that I want to thank the Academy
thank you so much Ryan Coogler
[Applause]
I stand here stronger than I was
yesterday his stand here with agency and
self-worth because of Ryan Coogler
they're not only made me a better
designer a better storyteller a better
person
I stand here because of this man who
offered me a different perspective of
life who offered me a safe space whose
patient and gave me air humanity and
brotherhood thank you I and I love you
and this prom there because of Marvel
who gave me the opportunity to do my
best who supported the Dean of the stone
and lifted us up every day
Victoria Alonso Kevin Feige Luz Esposito
and the man with the best class ever
Nate Moore thank you and he was stronger
because when the art department crew who
loved with their hearts and brought
their experiences talent courage
humility and hard work to the table
supervising art director Allen hook and
set decorator Jane Hart
thank you I'm stronger day because of
this wonderful cast who every day
stepped into this world and breathed
life into it because a rue Carter and
Rachel Morrison and everything they did
behind the camera with me I'm stronger
because of a woman because of a woman
who supported me every day that I wanted
to give up this is for you my friend
Carol Trevino rest in power I'm stronger
because of my family just supported me
through the rest of process of times I
give the strength to all of those who
come next to keep going to never give up
and when you think it's impossible just
remember to say this piece of advice I
got from a very wise woman I did my best
and my best is good enough thank you
[Applause]